Okay.
This is what
I think would be closer to what Henry
the fifth a combat leader would have
sounded like as he,
as he answered some one of his subordinate
leaders out there in the crowd,
seen that we need more
people. We need more men.
I think this is what he
would have sounded like.
What's he that wishes? So
my cousin Westmoreland.
No, my fair cousin. If
we are marked to die,
we are enough to do our country
loss and if to live the fewer men,
the greater share of honor. God's will.
I pray thee wish. Not One more man
by jove.
I am not covetous for gold nor
care I who doth feed upon my cost.
It earns me not if men,
my garments wear such
outward things dwell,
not my desires, but
if it be a sin to covet honor,
I am the most offending soul alive.
No faith, my Coz wish,
not a man from England.
God's peace.
I would not lose so great
an honor as one man more me,
things would share from me
for the best hope I have.
Oh, do not wish one more.
Rather proclaim it Westmoreland through
my host that he which hath no stomach to
this fight.
Let him depart his passport shall be
made and crowns for convoy shall be put
into his purse.
We would not die in that man's company
that fears his fellowship to die with us.
This Day is called the feast of Crispian.
He that outlives this day and comes home
safe will stand a tiptoe when the day
is named and rouse him
at the name of Crispian.
He that shall see this day and live all
the age will yearly on the vigil feast
his neighbors and say,
tomorrow is Saint Crispian.
Then will he strip his sleeve and show
his scars and say these wounds I had on
Crispin's Day
old men forget yet all shall be forgot,
but he'll remember with advantages
what feats he did that day.
Then shall our names familiar
in his mouth as household words.
Harry, the King Bedford and
Exeter, Warwick and Talbot,
Salisbury and Gloucester
be in their flowing cups,
freshly remembered
this story shall the good man teaches son
at Crispin Crispian shall ne'er go by
from this day to the ending of the world.
But we in it shall be
remembered. We, phew.
Yeah,
we happy few. We band of brothers
for cook for he today that sheds his
blood with me shall be my brother.
The ne'er so vile this day
shall gentle his condition
and gentlemen in England now a bed
shall think themselves or curse it.
They were not here and
hold their manhoods cheap.
Whiles any speaks that fought with us
upon Saint Crispin's Day.